it was great being young but at the same
time you know I think we're a little
stupid then you learn though from your
dad because your dad I remember going up
to your house and you were working out
and your dad was there and he was
working out and we talked and we got
along right away because he was uh so
you're comparing how many back surgeries
each one of you had right yeah I also
became friends with Stallone on set
because of the saint you had the same
surgery you know that [__] guy's got
no bedside man out there it was [__]
but um
but your your dad had a lot of injuries
yeah weren't his knees shot his hips
what how many issues did he have I mean
I think my dad had 15 surgeries in his
life from what
I mean he was also an idiot when he was
younger I mean he also was you know
he he rode motorcycles he was a cowboy a
Rodeo Cowboy he did all of his own
stunts he I mean every dumb thing you
could do and then when I say dumb I mean
we all do we don't learn from mistakes
and I kind of looked up to that when I
was a kid I'm like I want to have 11
surgeries you know like I I actually
thought like that's what makes you a man
what I'm what I the difference is my old
man he never he never got to where we
are where he became cautious he was
still wilding out till he was in his 70s
and early 80s I mean he he did a back
surgery that they told them like you
can't do this surgery he's like I'm
gonna do it you know and he would still
um so I think the difference is I
learned as we get older we got to age a
little bit you know I've been
training Brazilian Jiu Jitsu for 25 30
years almost I don't train the way I
trained when I was in my 20s because if
I did I'd have more surgeries and I'd be
more jammed up but you gotta I think you
gotta adjust and
you know be the best 40 and be the best
50 and be the best 60 not at 60 still
trying to be 40. you know that's when
you get jammed up I mean look back when
you grew up I mean you had a movie star
as a dad yeah it's no secret yeah I mean
you know I talked to Kiefer about it and
you know he said some things about you
know growing because it's got to be
different I had a dysfunctional family
and for all many different reasons and
um
but what what was it like like growing
up that you could recall was it was it
he was always working no he didn't work
a ton
um when I was growing up he um
I mean I look my dad was he wasn't
you're you're a calm no like a normal
actor guy you know he was really good at
everything he was an amazing athlete he
was good on a motorcycle he was a cowboy
he he was he could play any instrument
he picked up anything and could get good
at it he was like a um
uh uh not a mimic but like if you should
if he saw someone doing something he
could pick that thing up and he could do
it he was you know I wouldn't even say
Jack of all trades because he was really
good at all of everything you know he
was like a master at a lot of different
things and uh to me him being an actor
was just something else that he was good
at you know what I mean to me he wasn't
like an actor he was just somebody who
was really tough really handsome really
smart
girls liked him he was good at
everything like
that's got to be hard for you as a kid
my dad is everything how am I going to
Aspire to no I mean I think it made me
wanna do be good at stuff and you know
he used to tell me like he'd say if
you're going to do something be the best
at it or don't do it and I think you
know if you say that today people are
like don't tell your kid that is you
know like he was like first places for
second place is the first loser you know
what I'm saying like that's how he was
right and I really appreciate that and I
don't think that that's like accepted
today and
um no it wasn't hard it was really
something awesome to look up to so to
answer your question to me he wasn't an
actor he wasn't working a ton when I was
younger
um but when he did it was just something
else that he did really well to me does
that make sense absolutely you had a
respect for him yeah he was he was as
far as I was concerned he could have
played shortstop for the Yankees do you
know what I mean or he could have been a
professional fighter he could have been
a Prof he was a professional Rodeo
Cowboy he was you know he he could ride
dirt bikes I mean he he just was good at
stuff so I mean in the movie rollerball
did he really learn how to do all that
thousand percent a thousand so crazy and
like yeah he was he you know
he um
he he wasn't an actor to me is what I'm
getting at did he have I mean he he has
this innate intensity about him that
you're just you watch him and you want
to listen to him yes he was that intense
was he intense with you yeah I mean he
my dad didn't ever have to I mean you
know maybe give me a whack once or twice
bulb and whack but he never had to he
just look at me funny and I was like
okay my mom too my mom was tough like my
mom you know whatever she looked at me
sideways and I just did what she said I
mean you know I've never
I never we don't scare our kids you know
today like right but I was scared of
both my parents in a healthy way I feel
like yeah you know
um but you know what they also you know
I don't want to sit here and talk them
both up like they were they were both
[__] up a ton you know what I mean
flawed and made mistakes and it was a
different time and but um but anyway to
answer your question he uh I just I felt
like I got to grow up with someone who
had a lot of amazing qualities to look
up to and now as I get older the
qualities that weren't worth looking up
to were also a lesson you know what I
mean he was like that was gonna be my
question right yeah he's a he was like a
he he was like watching a hero's tale
and a cautionary tale at the same time
and getting the best out of both and I
think man that's all we can do right
like yeah get the best you know I try to
tell my daughter she was like this kid
was mean to me yesterday I'm like look
how that kid treated you all you can do
in life is see how people do things how
it makes you feel and decide whether or
not you want to make people feel that
way or you know what I mean like yeah
that's great advice and just like you
know you don't have to be that way right
yeah you don't have to do that or you
can choose to do that do you let you
know if you know you want to make people
feel that way you can do that I hope you
don't but yeah you know everything's
ever if we're smart everything is either
uh something to live up to or push or
stay away from and I think my parents
were so black and white in that way that
I was able to learn the good and and be
like Oh I'm not going to do that you
know